what's the deal with airplane
peanuts over the past couple of years
the list of massive venues being sold
out by comedians just keeps on growing
from Madison Square Garden Fen White
Park and Dodger Stadium to back-to-back
nights in NBA arenas there's never been
more comics doing shows of this
magnitude in the history of standup
comedy just cool to see jokes in an
arena in this video not only are we
going to be taking a look at Andrew
Schultz's back-to-back soldout shows in
the Toronto Raptors arena last weekend
and kill Tony already selling out two
shows in HB Arena this January but we'll
also run down the full list of current
Arena acts and standup and what comedy
fans should expect when attending these
massive shows he's like I'm so sorry to
say this but we can't do kill Tony on
that Sunday cuz we're only doing it in
Austin now and uh blah blah blah blah
blah and a bunch of other stuff blah
blah blah we're in Arena act uh blah
blah blah sold out Arenas in our
hometown I know I was trying to save you
from looking like a douchebag
um the full list of comedians who have
an arena booked on their current or
upcoming tours include Adam Sandler
Andrew Schultz Bert ker Bill Burr Liza
slesinger fluffy the Impractical Jokers
Jack White Hall Jeff Dunham Joe Koy Cat
Williams Nate barazi Ryan Hamilton
Trevor Noah and kill Tony what's even
crazier than that list is that in the
history of Madison Square Garden which
has longly been considered the top of
the mountain in terms of standup venues
only 20 different Comics have headlined
m G however out of those 20 15 of those
shows have taken place since 2010
meaning it has been getting more and
more popular for comedians to accomplish
this feat than ever before look up bands
that have sold out MSG or what comedians
have
Chappelle Chris Rock John malany yeah
sold it at once whoa who's more famous
ber Cher or D Porto bar Cher bar Cher
does Arenas in like
Australia's huge dude it would be like
there's people that have so many
followers who couldn't sell at MSG I
don't think there's like do you think
that like like there's a lot of bar I
know I know I'm aware yeah you're
probably right he probably could sell it
out ah no I'm standing by my ground he
would he would stand ground I'm not
saying that I know Dave is massive and
he might be more famous than ber Cher
but 15 thou seven 18,000 people at one
night in one spot is a load of people
like we mentioned earlier the most
recent comic to perform at a venue this
size is none other than Andrew Schultz
who just had two shows in Scotia Bank
Arena this past weekend which adds up to
a total close to 40,000 tickets sold for
Schultz in just one city which is pretty
awesome same deal with the kill Tony New
Year's Eve show that's happening in
Austin a few months from now HB Arena
does hold significantly less people than
a professional sporting venue but for a
live podcast this is nuts and you got to
assume this is only the beginning for
both Kil Tony and Andrew Schultz moving
up to this next level that is
unbelievable he's doing this podcast in
an arena on New Year's Eve
congratulations that's [__] amazing
there's no doubt these shows becoming
Larger than Life is a net positive for
everyone involved from the comics to the
fans and the whole industry in general
and while attending an arena show can be
fun to witness the spectacle of one of
your favorite comedians performing in
front of thousands of people in the
round it might not be the best
atmosphere to experience actual standup
For the joke's sake eventually the size
of the venue starts to get in the way of
the performance the audio is typically a
bit off and Scratchy you end up watching
most of the show on the Jumbotron and
there is a lot more of a disconnect
between you and the comedian that's why
Arena shows are cool but for a different
reason if you've been a fan of someone
like Andrew Schultz for a long time
seeing him perform where the Raptors
play almost feels like a celebration
that you get to be a part of but if you
wanted to see the very best version of
him doing standup because you love
comedy I don't think anyone would
suggest sitting in a crowd of 177,000
other people getting to see someone in a
club or a theater is bound to be a
better show the seats are tighter the
ceilings are lower the sound is better
and it's easier to truly lock into the
performance and watch the comedian on
stage obviously everyone has their own
preferences at the end of the day so I
would definitely recommend going to see
live comedy at as many different venues
as possible to form your own idea of
what you prefer guest spots from last
week The Joe Rogan Experience had on
Eddie Bravo Steve stro and Joe list two
bears one cave was Bert and cyh of
sounds kill Tony this week was with Adam
/ Dr Phil and Sam Talent ymh talked with
Danny Brown we might be drunk at on Roy
Wood Jr Matt and Shane secret podcast
was just the boys aru garbage had a
hilarious two episodes with Rich Voss
and Sam Mill taste buds invited Anthony
Bowens on the show to battle Waffle
House vers Denny's Jake Johnson was a
guest on Whiskey Ginger El Presidente
made his second appearance on flagrant
and bad friends sat down with Oliver
tree it's a [__] extra little you
know what people that aren't happy a
black pereria look at that I'm walking
Bob you're going to lose our that's it
you're losing our guest I'm not doing
this [__] [__] again [__] dud I'm
sorry dudee don't do that right now dude
dude I'm sorry man where's the other
exit milk there's no other exit dude
that's whiskey
Ginger I told you this was going to
happen well why did you why did you egg
him on I just said a hint I didn't say
he literally called me before the show
and was like he's going to [__] walk
why are you making him walk he honestly
Oliver Oliver apologize Oliver that's
andw he's going to be M Andrew he
literally took your golf back can't do
this [__] [__] anymore I come here
I'm just literally trying to be the
nicest [__] guy this past weekend
with theovon had on Robert Kennedy Jr
the Tim Dylan show talked with Dan Soder
Dan was also the guest on bertcast the
blocks podcast had on Tony Hawk Lis J
Gomez went on only fans tyo celebrated
episode number 15 with Adam Ray tiger
belly had on Steph Tov Being Ian with
Jordan welcomed Graham K Jeffrey asmus
visited stav's World Douglas Murray made
it to to the Boys cast and Fred armison
was the guest on the Harland Highway as
far as new standup specials are either
out right now or coming out soon country
Wayne brings his Larger than Life Family
Tales to Netflix with his debut special
a woman's prayer giving all of us a
hilarious insight into his journey as a
father of 10 we also had 30 minutes with
Rich Voss the final installment of the
30 minutes with series produced by gas
digital a series that also featured
specials from Kurt mezer Lis J Gomez
Dave Smith colum Terell and Jordan
Jensen which can all be found on each of
their individual YouTube channels
speaking of gas digital helping produce
specials for other comedians Joe
Zimmerman released his new special cult
classic over on Nate bargo's Nate land
YouTube channel making this the third
YouTube special released this year by
Nate land thank you thank you thank you
Asheville best crowds in the world right
here in Asheville North
Carolina and I say that everywhere I
go I was just in Atlanta I was like best
crowds in the world Asheville North
Carolina that's right we also have a few
new specials that will be coming out
relatively soon Matt R's Netflix special
natural selection will be out on Netflix
later this year and both Kim conden and
S alcano have their debut standup
specials coming out soon sometime in
early 2024 the contest still stands if
you are going to any of my tapings any
of the four tapings for my standup
comedy special I'm going to choose one
ticket it doesn't matter where you sit
and it doesn't matter what taping you're
at I'm going to Cho chose one person
give you a plus one I'm going to fly you
to New York put you up in a hotel and
bring you on a set of Impractical Jokers
I want to do that as a thank you to you
guys because I couldn't believe it sold
out so fast this video is probably going
to be uploaded a tad later than normal
just because this past weekend we had
the honor of attending skang Fest 2023
in Las Vegas which was an experience
that is almost impossible to describe
but we'll try our best in the official
full skang Fast recap video coming out
later this week on this channel it's
going to include some special interviews
with comedian behind the scenes footage
and answers to a lot of the questions
comedy fans have about this Festival
please consider subscribing right now to
make sure that you see that video right
when it comes out but most importantly
thank you so much for watching this
video at joke
world that's it
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out